hello
everybody
welcome to ask dog live
hope you are having a fabulous friday
for some of you it may be saturday
already hope you have a fabulous
saturday to ask stock live
so if you are here with us live and
would like to ask dr wallach a question
find in the zoom menu
raise hand
so sometimes you have to click on
reactions to see that raised hand option
but we want to make sure that if you
have a question and would like to speak
with dr wallach that you get your hand
raised early i'll be going back and
forth between the order that the hands
are raised and emails and messages that
i have received
and we want to try to get through as
many as quit as possible so
be ready when i ask you to unmute be
ready to unmute if you've got a camera
let's get your camera turned on by the
way dr wallace can see you face to face
and get more information
from seeing you physically
in addition to the questions that he's
asking
all right
so my name is rebecca dukes kozak and i
am proud to be the host of this show ask
doc live i am joined with my co-hosts
jonty mccollier ruth ann sanchez dr judy
reynolds and
if you're on live with us make sure that
you have that chat open so that you can
see all the important information that
ruth ellen and dr judy will be putting
into
that chat including the way some of the
products are spelled
um links
to information that supports what dr
wallach is sharing with us today and
also links to how to get some of his
books because
he is an amazing amazing man with all of
the research and then putting that
research into
books that are available to the public
that empower us to be able to take
control of our own health
folks i don't know about you but when i
figured out that i could do that myself
life just got better
so the fact that you are here joining us
is a huge testament to
the fact that you value yourself you
value your family your friends
and want to make sure that you are
getting information
about what you can do
to
have better control
to create a
more positive life for yourself and
your family
so everybody
hold on tight
i want you to know that
we do have to say
the fda requires to let you know let you
know that our products are not meant to
treat prevent diagnose or cure any
diseases this program is not meant to
take the place of your primary care
physician but our good doctor dr joel
wallick
has been instrumental in suiting suing
this fine establishment with nine
victories these victories have all led
to the addition of vital nutrients being
added to foods and
most importantly
allowing the distribution of information
that has been proven by science to be
factual
in the essential need of supplementation
against disease
a lot of people say oh well there's no
science behind that or if it doesn't
come from my doctor
then it can't be true because my doctor
didn't tell me about it well guess what
folks there's science beyond your doctor
and we empower you encourage you to take
a look at it
we also bring you the good news that the
genetic theory has been proven to be
incorrect
just because mom and grandma had a
certain blood sugar issue
or bone issue does not mean that you
have to have that issue
also the science of epigenetics has
proven
that
you have control
what we put into our bodies the things
in our environment
they
will help to decide how our genes are
expressed
and with those
gene expressions determines whether or
not we're going to have these conditions
so you as an individual
through the science of epigenetics
are empowered to
take control of your health journey
we invite you to feel the difference and
to guide us on this journey we have the
one and only the amazing dr joel wallach
welcome dollar dr wallach to ask doc
live
and before before you start i do want to
say
that this program is being sponsored by
askdoclive.com where we do have a store
there but if somebody invited you to
this program
make sure that you get back to them
tell them how thankful you are that they
share this information with you and you
want to take control of your own health
journey chances are it was one of our
health coaches and they have the ability
to coach you in making sure that you're
getting the products that you need
and they may also have
their own special way of ordering so get
back with the person that invited you to
this program
if you found it because of one of our
newsletters
or just browsing along you can go to
askdoclive.com and use the contact us
for questions on what you need to get
specifically for you
now dr wallach
i know you have a lot of information to
share with us you always are so full of
information
what do you have for us today and
welcome to a stock live
well thank you so much rebecca and thank
you for your entire team i just we're
family and i can't thank you enough for
all the great things you do for humanity
so i applaud you thank you so much
um i want to start out with a couple of
things
one you asked me a question about do we
need to supplement with vitamin d3
and of course the answer is yes even if
you live in sunny california even if you
live in louisiana or florida you need to
supplement with vitamin d3
and people say well i'm a vegetarian i'm
not going to take vitamin d3 because it
comes from an animal
well vitamin d3 is found in milk
okay whether it's your mother's milk or
cow's milk or goat's milk or
whatever it's found in milk
and it was actually in addition to being
in there naturally it was put in milk
that's why they have on the label
vitamin d3
milk
um
because during the 1920s and all the
factories from 1890 to 1920 when
electricity was really hitting hard
um all these new factories were coming
out
and they were going away from all the
smoke from the from the coal and the
wood
driven factories and things but there
was so much smoke in the air at that
time
that uh just about every kid in america
had
osteoporosis every kid in america
rickets okay and so they put vitamin d3
in the milk and within months the
rickets went away
okay so that's why there's that's the
history of vitamin d3 and milk was put
in there during the 19 early 1900s to
deal with the plague of rickets okay
because of the smoke and the air block
and the sunlight that's why that
happened so that's why it's in there
everybody needs to be supplemented with
vitamin d3 okay
and when you live in a sunny place or
not because most adults when you're in a
sunny place they sit in the shade it's
the kids that take off their shirts and
run around out in the sun
okay
and so
um you have to deal with that now the
oldest living person right now is a
south african woman by the name of
johanna
uh mazi buko
johanna mazzy buco m-a-z-i-b-u-k-o
and johanna
mazibuko may
11th
may 11th
uh let's see here
uh may 11th
18th
get that right where am i oh here we go
she turned
after she was born
and this may 11 she turned 128.
in a cool 128 and she's still going she
lives she does not live in a nursing
home she's at home
and she functions by herself she does
use a walker she has a little bit of
hearing problems so the odds are she has
osteoporosis of the skull even though
she lives in a very sunny country
in south africa
i'm sure she's got some osteoporosis to
the skull
but she's doing pretty good for 128
years of age still able to
uh take a walk with her grandkids and
walk her grandkids in school and all
that kind of stuff so i think that's
very very very telling you have to
appreciate you do have to supplement
because nutritional minerals do not
occur in a uniform blank around the
crusty earth nutritional minerals occur
in veins like gold and silver plants can
make vitamins plants can make
beta-carotene aka vitamin a they can
make vitamin c
plants can make vitamin e plants can
make b vitamins but plants cannot
manufacture minerals nutritional
minerals do not occur in a uniform blank
around the trust of the earth they occur
in veins like gold and silver
and so depending on where you live is
going to depend on how many minerals you
get from your food
so the only way to guarantee you're
going to get them all is to
incorporate the a
program
okay of essential factors every day i've
been doing it for 75 years i'm 83 years
old most people think i'm in my 50s or
early 60s when they look at me
they can't believe i'm 83
and it's one of those things where
um
if you do everything correctly you can
add 25 to 50 healthy years your life if
you just go along and just eat well
quote unquote
and don't take the essential factors
constantly
okay to make sure you're getting them
every day
three times a day well guess what
the odds are you're gonna die because
our average life expectancy in america
is only 75.
okay we rank about 45th of the
industrialized nations when it comes to
longevity
there's 44 other industrialized nations
whose peoples live longer than us
japanese are amongst them they live to
be on the average
uh 84.7 we live to be 75 they live just
about 10 years longer than we do
and that's because
of what they eat how they eat
and how they supplement okay
and so
you have to do the same thing otherwise
you're going to cheat yourself
if you if you take your essential
factors and stay away from the bad stuff
like wheat barley around oats and
maximize absorption
you'll be able to spend 25 to 50 more
years with the people you love you'll be
able to spend 25 to 50 more years doing
the stuff you love to do okay this is
not difficult
then
uh i want to jump next
to um
guillain-barre syndrome
this was actually established
and published in 1916 by two french
doctors one a doctor guillain and the
other one dr beret okay so they called
it the guillain-barre syndrome
and it's identical to ms
okay but this occurred in kids
back in the
early 1900s
and of course they called in autoimmune
disease
and many people today still call it
autoimmune disease gmbra syndrome but
it's actually just nutritional
deficiencies as you can tell by now
okay
and so it's one of those things where
they have a demyelinating
problem with their brain and spinal cord
so they have all this peripheral
neuropathies and all kinds of stuff
going on
because the brain isn't functioning
properly because the myelin is gone and
myelin is eighty percent fat and twenty
percent protein
myelin the insulation and covering of
the brain and brain cells and the nerves
um is eighty percent fat and twenty
percent protein that eight percent fat
is significantly uh depends on what part
of the brain you're talking about it
might be 20
30 40 50
cholesterol
cholesterol is an essential part of your
central nervous system your brain your
spinal cord and all the peripheral
nerves and it's one of those things
where
your brain cells can make cholesterol
okay
if it gets all the right fats
and so
um it's just the opposite of what
doctors would talk cholesterol is as bad
as shooting yourself in the head with a
45 bullet no cholesterol is one of your
best friends
okay
and so you have to make sure that these
kids
are getting um
two to three eggs a day with soft yolks
so they can get the the cholesterol and
raw materials from the egg yolks just
remember that egg
if it's fertile
that egg the the kick when when the egg
is laid
the chick is one millimeter in diameter
a little white spot on top of the yolk
that's the chick
okay
and when it's incubated for 26 days the
chick pecks its way out of the egg and
it has a heart that's beating it has
lungs that get oxygen it has a liver and
kidneys at work it has muscles and bones
has a brain and spinal cord that does
everything has eyes as a digestive
system
all that came from the nutrition in that
egg
the egg is one of the most nutritious
foods in the world next to mama's milk
okay
and so you need to be eating eggs i eat
three eggs twice a day with soft milk
soft sauce scrambling butter i can pour
my scrambled eggs off of the little bowl
um
because it's liquid i don't get them
it's where they're solid because then
you've killed so many of the nutrients
okay
and so don't forget that's why these
kids have all these emotional problems
because especially you know they're
getting some kind of variation of
guillain-barre syndrome
because
i don't want to eat eggs okay here have
some weeds
breakfast to champions but then there's
lifespan professional athletes at 62
except for basketball players
is what
30 31
okay and so it's one of those things
where you have to say okay the breakfast
of champions really isn't the best thing
for you
because the gluten in the wheaties kills
your intestines your intestines uh look
like a shag rug when you cut open an
intestine during surgery or maybe an
autopsy
the little finger like villa make it
look like a shag rug when you eat gluten
within months those villi go away and
now your intestines look like a plastic
tube
you've lost 90 percent of the absorptive
surface
now everybody
with gambere syndrome everybody
with um
excuse me
alzheimer's disease and and that kind of
stuff
ms multiple sclerosis
they're they all have celiac disease
excuse me they all have celiac disease
that's telling you something
another piece with the
uh guillain-barre and also the
um
things like
ms multiple sclerosis
women
have three times the rate of multiple
sclerosis as men
women have four times the rate of muscle
sclerosis excuse me four times the rate
of
osteoporosis is men now is that a gender
thing no it's a dietary thing women
don't want to get fat and have wrinkly
skin so they avoid animal fats
okay they avoid all kinds of stuff and
you want to be vegetarians and
fruitarians and all this kind of stuff
to keep their weight down
and they get all these deficiencies
because they don't take their essential
factors when you start restricting your
diet like that that's why women
have such a rough time when it comes to
ms
and osteoporosis
really really tragic but it's just their
behavior it's their choices of food and
not taking essential factors
okay they think well i'm eating well i
eat vegetables and i eat fruit for every
meal well do you days oh no that's got
cholesterol in it uh do you eat red meat
oh no no no that's got cholesterol and i
don't want that and so that's why i'm
just a fruitarian okay well you better
start shopping around for coffins
because you're going to die early and
you're going to be miserable between now
and the time you die you don't want to
do that
and
ms
dion beret syndrome
i believe and obviously approach to the
skull
all three of those are related okay and
you can have all three at the same time
you have two of the three
and
it depends on what age you are it's
going to be what what name they give it
you know if you're a teenager they're
going to call it ganbare syndrome if
you're an adult they're going to call it
um
they're going to call it ms
and so it's one of those things where
you know the truth now and so you know
what to do get off all the bad stuff no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no gluten no wheat by rhinos no sugar no
carbonated drinks
and cross contamination which we were
talking about before we came on the air
from food preparation surfaces
in the restaurants and things
you'll get cross-contaminated and food
preparation surfaces in the laundry and
so on uh if you're washing your clothes
let's say you have a spouse who works in
a bakery and you wash your clothes in
the same washer and dryer they do guess
what
you're getting cross-contaminated you're
getting gluten even though you're not
eating it you're getting it through skin
contact because you're washing your
clothes in the same washer and dryer
that they're washing their clothes
they're just covered
in wheat dust
okay doesn't work in a bakery
and it's one of those things where
um
the doctors have no clue
okay and they give you all these names
oh you have
ms you have multiple sclerosis and it
comes and goes it comes and goes and
comes and goes but you're not gonna live
a long healthy life your life's gonna be
miserable all the way till we're finally
you're shopping around for coffins
because i i know i'm gonna die tomorrow
i can't live like this
kind of thing
okay
and this is not difficult and this is
why we have
the healthy brain and heart pack
we have the healthy brain and heart pack
which is our big hammer it has 215
nutrients in it including the 90 of
course it's 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12
minutes and 3 fatty acids
and
doing these sort of things i've been
able to get rid of so many diseases i'm
the guy who
discovered the fact that um
cystic fibrosis was not a genetic
disease of humans i found the first case
documented in a non-human primate at the
yerkes primate center
in emory university in in atlanta
georgia in 19
let's see here 1967
okay 1967
and when i got it documented that it was
in fact
cystic roses
and
i centered around just the slides and i
didn't tell them from a monkey i said i
think this is cystic fibrosis what do
you think they all said yeah the medical
school said yeah that's a classic
example and i told it was from a monkey
and at the very least we have
a animal model now they were so excited
i was in every newspaper every radio
show every tv show every day for about
three months
okay and then i got permission to do
biopsy in the other baby
facility and they all had cystic
fibrosis i said this is not genetic this
is a simple nutritional deficiency and
they fired me and so i started going to
trade shows looking for something to do
and i found the school mcnam national
college and having medicine in portland
oregon went there and taught
nutrition and pathology and at the same
time i was taking classes and so in 1982
i graduated as a naturopathic physician
naturopathic doctor
and that's that began my career as a
physician
sort of
post veterinarian
and then um i was working with
kids who had muscular dystrophy
and um one of our great distributors of
marvin romp a marine
he lives up in idaho and utah and we uh
we're working with all these kids with
musculoskeletal in the amish community
and we were curing them and so we took
five of them and brought them to jerry
lewis on the records and the doctors had
signed off they don't have much history
anymore by biopsy he didn't have it
anymore and jerry lewis got excited he
took these
[Music]
documents okay their clinical records
and the sign-offs by these doctors they
didn't have musculus anymore to the
muscular association remember
over a period of 50 years he did the
telethon for the most history
association raised 2.7 billion dollars
for them over 50 years and they
immediately fired jerry lewis because he
agreed that musculus was not a genetic
thing
so they fired jerry lewis
okay and then
um at the same time all this information
uh dr milan and i we went to heilum
zhang province china um keyshawn
university
and there's a disease there called
keyshawn disease in that particular
province there's a mineral missing in
the soil there and just about every kid
if they're not taking the essential
factors will die from hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy heart disease which is
essentially um son of a death syndrome
and mothers were not laying on their
babies 99 of them died in the crib so i
made them change the name to crib death
instead of
sentiment death syndrome because the
mothers were not laying on the babies
and smothering them that was all i mean
that was a doctor's concoction to cover
their buffs because they didn't know why
the babies were dying so they blamed it
on the mother laying on them that was
not true they were dying in their crib
and so
i was able to prove
that these babies were and it took us
about 20 more years my great attorney
jonathan emorg
we fought the fda we sued them
i think ultimately 12 times we beat them
every time we forced them to put these
nutrients into the baby farmless
and in 1990 when all this was happening
the rate of sediment death syndrome was
135 to 140 per hundred thousand normal
births
today it's 15 to 20 and we dropped it by
90 by putting
these nutrients into the baby formulas
infamils similac and the like so i'm
very very proud of that
um it's a great great great history and
it's only just begun we figure we've got
another 25 to 50 years left we have a
whole list of other diseases we're
working on
and so
um this is one of those things where
we have a track record
we have a track record and so the gambo
ray thing i believe we're going to make
make that disappear
uh next uh ms i'm going to make that
appear multiple scrolls that's going to
disappear
because it's not an autoimmune disease
the body's not attacking itself it's a
simple nutritional deficiency thing
and
we are
excited
because just think about it cystic
fibrosis is gone
musculoskeletal is gone so the death
syndrome is gone and now we're working
on
um the
um guyanberry syndrome and also
we're working on
a thing called
multiple sclerosis ms
so with all that
we're going to add many healthy years to
people's lives at the same time
and so it's a win-win-win-win-win-win
situation
and i can't thank you and your team
enough rebecca for
allowing me to share all this because
it's going to add many healthy years to
people's lives over to you
well we're empowering people dr wellick
we're very proud of you you have to
depend on a system that is broken
let's be in power folks
now dr wellick you had mentioned about
formula
and getting nutrients added to formula
and right now there is in the united
states an issue with getting formula
it's like people have forgotten how to
feed babies without
some type of processed food
well for thousands of years before the
formulas came along
um people were using goat's milk um and
they were using
cow's milk llama milk camel milk
okay and so this is not this is not
anything new uh because mothers had to
work out in the fields and all this and
the other they didn't want to come home
and breastfeed a baby because they've
been working out in the sun all day uh
sweating and working hard and they just
want to come home
drink a little bit of water and go to
sleep
and so um they they began grandma
you know grandma was 60 70 80 years old
she couldn't breastfeed the baby so
she started you know giving him the
goat's milk and the cow's milk and the
and the um
milk from llamas and so forth
and sheep's milk and so on
and
um
that's how it worked and they would put
maybe a couple of drops of something you
know like um
oh
they would put so
maybe something that had honey or
something like that in it to make it
taste a little sweet make it taste good
so the babies would drink it up
because it tasted like a llama so
they put a little bit of honey uh in
there to make it taste better
and um maybe they put a kind of a
teaspoon or maybe not that much maybe a
quarter of a teaspoon of wood ashes
into the goat's milk along with the
honey and the wood ashes were minerals
of course
and that's what the babies got as their
supplement as their as their
um their drink okay uh when mothers were
out there in the fields working
and so 75 80 year old grandmother was
giving them
the formula that they had created
so let's talk about what formula we can
create now
in order to feed our babies because
i know
wood ash
is not available
like it used to be
and then if you do do ash
i get concerned about you know plastics
being in there when the things were
burning and having that toxicity so
we're going to go for a non-toxic
formula
and what dr wallach is holding up it's
called our kids toddy so i know it
there's a little bit of a glare on it
but kids toddy
can be added to the formula and given to
them and it's
the dosage is right there on the label
yeah those on the back label how much
per pound or how much for 10 pounds of
body weight
um it tastes good it's a liquid that
tastes like lemonade but it can be added
to cow's milk and goat's milk and
just plain old
milk you know
pour out of the bottle
um cow's milk
at the table i'll go ahead and add this
to it and don't forget the cherrymans
use the same dosage scale and then of
course the efas are very important to
prevent asthma and stuff like that
and so
this is something that's kind of going
like crazy right now because of this the
formula problem
and of course i've been looking at the
analyses of the formulas they're getting
from the uk and so forth all the other
countries germany
and
sure enough they do have
my formula okay they made my formula
because
they didn't have the same laws we did
but when we forced our manufacturers to
put these nutrients into the baby
farmers to prevent sediment death
syndrome guess what all the foreign
countries began to do the same thing so
these formulas coming from the uk and
also from germany have those nutrients
in there because i was going to make a
big stink if they didn't were not in
those formulas
yeah
right
and the nice thing about what you're
holding up right there dr wallach that
formula
it's concentrated it does not take very
much
in order to get into that child
what is needed as the foundation the 90
essential nutrients the essential
factors
yes the essential factors because
without those factors our body just
can't
thrive
might be able to survive
but not thrive for a short time not
maximally
that's right well we're looking for
maximum why go small we're going big we
want it all dr wallach all right
hands that want it all
as well so we're gonna get to those
hands i've got my hand up
um
but i just want to remind everybody
thank you so much for joining us on ask
doc live make sure that you get back to
the person
or the newsletter or however you heard
about us get back with them
and say thank you for sharing this
information with me i want more info
because we have so much to share that we
just cannot share it in the short two
hours and it does go by fast
let's go to our first hand that is up
and vicky
go ahead and unmute yourself if you're
able to turn a camera on fantastic
okay
hi
okay can you hear me okay
we can hear you great how can we help
you you're on live with dr pollock
all right hi dr wild thank you for this
i've got two questions i've got one
about my son who is 34 years old 510 and
weighs over 300 pounds
and um i just sent him um
one of the
the packs
but i i'm assuming we're gonna have to
triple the dose that what i'm taking for
him is that correct
okay he he should be getting does he
have any other issues high blood
pressure diabetes arthritis
surprisingly no
i bet he does
well he does take medication
and he takes
okay yeah he takes um
what do you call it something for um
well he takes prozac okay
and he takes um
something for his adv
those two things okay and so
i i guarantee he's got other issues
going on
okay you may not be complaining about it
maybe just taking some aspirin for his
arthritis and that kind of stuff
but anyway uh and you say he's five ten
at five ten i'd like to see him weigh
180 so he's 120 pounds
uh overweight okay
and um so i need him
to um
take uh uh optimally he would take three
healthy brain and heart packs a month
photos everything
breakfast photos or anything at lunch
and fill everything at dinner time
if finance isn't an issue don't go any
lower than two healthy branded heart
packs a month the full goes for your
breakfast a little drinking dinner time
also
you need to get two bottles a month of
our msm so you can take three at
breakfast street lunch dinner time and
they will support um
and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone makes
it
which includes the bone marrow which is
his
immune system
okay and um i also want him to have the
collagen peptides he could take uh one
of those canisters to take a scoop of
this breakfast drink and scoop his
evening drink he needs vitamin d3 which
he spoke about earlier he needs three of
those three times today it'll be three
miles a month at the bottom of d3
and then to help him lose the weight
i want him to get
um
let's see here
one
keto shake per day
one kilo shake per day it's a meal
replacer it's not to add to a meal it's
a meal replacer
and two or three of the
uh rebound sports drinks okay has a
hundred nutrients in it
and so
again it's a meal replacer it's not to
add to a meal it doesn't have to be the
same meal every day but he will begin to
lose a half a pound of two pounds a day
and so within three or four or five
months he'll be down to where he needs
to be
now how long does he have to stay on all
these nutrients well the rest of his
life because if he gets off those
nutrients again it goes back to his old
ways within three to six months
he'll be back in trouble again okay so
he's got to stay on these things forever
this is not just a short time deal
okay this is forever how long you need
oxygen forever how i need water forever
how long you need the essential
nutrients forever okay
okay quickly second question
my second is about myself i'm 66 5'3
weigh 126. i have migraines and
allergies
and i have been on the pack um
i am seeing a chiropractor because i've
got um
cervical discs that are out of place in
my neck
and uh but i'm still getting the
migraines
okay
do you have any ringing in your ears
no
okay do you have any vertigo or
dizziness
no
do any dental problems you know like
implants or
i i missed that all i heard was a buzz
no
okay no okay
all right
so at 126 pounds i want you to have get
all the bad stuff no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat by rhinos no sugar no carbonated
drinks either the diet one's got to go
because the carbonation in the diet
drinks neutralize your stomach acid so
you cannot absorb minerals and digest
food okay
then um i need you at 126 pounds to get
the one healthy branded heart pack uh
take a half of those during your
breakfast half a dozen dinner time go
ahead and take the msm get one bottle of
msm so you can take three breakfast
through dinner time
going to support and promote mains
repair cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between the
vertebrae bone makes including in your
neck and so forth
because if you got your neck you got
problems elsewhere they're just not
showing up yet okay yeah you don't get
osteoporosis just in just in one
vertebrae in the neck
okay
but you got symptoms there okay and then
that's why that's why the chiropractor
is working on your neck
but you gotta guarantee you got things
going on your knees they may be clicking
and popping they may have a little
tenderness at the end of the day or
something like that but you got stuff
going on in your knees and your hips and
your lower back
and so on and your fingers and your toes
it's just not as for whatever reason is
more intense in your neck okay
and then
then um i want you also to take as i
said the msm you can go ahead and take
one bottle of that so you can take three
at breakfast for dinner time that's
gonna support and promote mains repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between the vertebrae bone
matrix bone itself i want you to take
the collagen peptides one canister a
month so you can take a scoop of
breakfast scoop at dinner time
i also
uh let's see here
um
hmm
let's just go with that that's a handful
of stuff to start uh for a drink you can
use our rebound or sports drink you can
use that
okay as a drink i just don't take it
after four o'clock in the afternoon
because you'll stay up all night it has
a hundred nutrients in it red bull is
primarily sugar and caffeine
our sports drink is 100 nutrients
okay 75 minerals and 25 vitamins amino
acids
so give us a call and you know after two
weeks and four weeks and six weeks um
okay as you're ordering the product you
can start on the on the your diet
correction right now
don't wait until you get your stuff
you know to to work on your diet do you
start getting rid of the bad stuff
immediately
uh i in fact what i would do is box it
up and give it to your doctor
and then
write it off
as an expense
on your
taxes okay but don't you take it anymore
no uh what was the purpose of the sports
drink
okay you're getting vitamins and
minerals and energy
okay
getting vitamins minerals and energy
okay so you don't have to sit at the
table
for two hours and eat to get all that
stuff because you're gonna be able to
take it that drink with you and sip on
it as you're walking around and driving
and all this kind of stuff okay
okay very good thank you
you better appreciate it
okay
[Music]
all right dr wallach now i have a
question from jenny
jenny has a niece who's 12 years old
she is
5 foot 2
178 pounds
she has bilirubin and protein in her
urine
and they're wanting to know
what does she need to get on in order to
get this corrected
okay it sounds like she's great
let's that's what i thought too dr
wallach now her sister had her
gallbladder taken out
um a few years ago at the same age
because of gallstones
for this little girl
that if they're not able to get the
numbers right then they're going to be
looking at removing her gallbladder yeah
the doctors should go to jail
okay
okay so the older one
she needs to be doing the same thing
that i'm i'm going to give okay for this
little girl okay the older one is doing
the exact same thing because she didn't
have a gallbladder the good lord gave us
a gallbladder for a purpose
okay the gallbladder stores bile liquid
bile and every time you eat the
gallbladder contracts and squirt some of
that liquid bile into your intestines so
you can absorb
uh healthy fats fat soluble vitamins
okay things you need
you take out the gallbladder suddenly
now
you're only getting 10
or less of what you need to pull that
off
okay so people who have their
gallbladders removed
really should sue the doctor
because they're they're causing them to
not be able to
efficiently absorb their nutrition
the gallbladder is not the problem the
gallbladder is a victim here okay
but they need to get rid of all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens we brought rhinos no
sugar no carbonated drinks here the diet
one's got to go
and then based on 100 pounds
um
each of those girls need to be on one
healthy brain and heart pack per month
for 100 pounds of body weight
okay
um they need the collagen peptides to
scoop in that with their breakfast drink
and scoop that with their evening drink
they can use our rebounds for shrink and
then both of them
need our ultimate enzymes we call it the
gallbladder bottle because it does have
bile added to it we've added bile from
the gallbladders from beef that are
killed in a slaughterhouse
and so we have bile in there we called
the gallbladder the bottle it's our
ultimate enzymes both those girls need
to take one or two of those say five to
ten minutes for each meal with a little
bit of water
and it's going to resolve their symptoms
okay how long do they have to do this
well they both need to do this forever
especially the older one that's had her
gallbladder removed
okay
again those doctors should go to jail to
take a kid's gallbladder out you got to
be kidding me oh
no pun intended
okay all right let's keep going here
let's keep going so let's go to the next
hand that is up and hp
hp if you can unmute yourself
and if you have a camera you can turn on
absolutely fabulous you are on live with
dr wallach
dr wallach are you able to hear him
okay i see his lips moving and i show
that he's unmuted but i'm not able to
hear him
um
hb if you can make sure i'm gonna go to
the next person but if you could make
sure that you select the audio
um and use your wi-fi or device audio
we'll come back to you okay bud okay
oh there you go hey i heard you
you got me now
okay
so thanks for taking my call um dr
wallach i i spoke with you back in march
and i have two things i wanted to
address uh follow up on is my diabetes
and my cholesterol
uh back in november my i'm a six year
old male
um
six foot 198 198 is uh i haven't weighed
198 pounds since i was a junior in high
school so i i work out five days a week
i had a blood test back in november my
a1c was 10. i had a blood test uh two
days ago and it dropped to 6.8 which i'm
very happy and pleased with
um i'm on metformin uh it's been reduced
to uh
1 000 milligrams
it was twice a day but it's down to one
per day
um
and i just i don't know
i want to get off the medications is
basically what i'm trying to say
okay well stop stop stop okay so you
need to be on
two healthy brain and heart packs per
month
two healthy branded heart packs a month
that's our big hammer
okay
it has 215 nutrients in it including the
90 essential nutrients from the original
healthy start pack
215 nutrients okay
guaranteed and so you take that
twice a day that's two bottles of that
two about two packs give me two packs of
the healthy branded heart pack
per month take a full dose of any
practice photos or dinner time and also
at 198 pounds want you to take
um
two bottles a month of our sweeties two
bottles a month of sweeties take three
breakfast three days i'm on that okay
come on the sweeties i'm on the tang uh
tangerine the osteo fx and the efa plus
okay okay good well
just the fact that your a1c went from 10
down to six that's a good thing
right okay
so let's keep going but i i do want you
to
begin to slowly reduce your medication
correct
okay don't cold turkey off of it but say
cut it by 25 and see what happens in two
weeks yeah
okay absolutely yeah and uh can i just
address my uh cholesterol so
the cholesterol right now i'm on the uh
simva fastin
uh 20 milligrams my doctor increased to
40 milligrams back in november after my
blood test
i had a lot of the 20 milligrams left so
i just continued on that and i really
watched my diet um but it's just strange
that my my cholesterol actually went up
it went from 157 to 173
and my ldls went from 96 to 110 and i've
been really you know between exercising
and eating a lot better and i just i'm
puzzled on that
and his
his
answer to all this was i need more drugs
and okay well you need a different one
yeah you need to fire him
okay he needs firing
okay terminate your relationship with
that doctor
okay first of all cholesterol does not
cause plaque in the arteries
the doctors missed that one by a billion
miles
uh they are the ones who have created
all these problems by getting people off
of cholesterol and then give them statin
drugs are you on statin drugs
yeah the symbiosis and vaseline okay
well okay you need to cut it by 25
immediately
okay
and then you know then test yourself
again
okay for cholesterol
and then it's the whole goal here is
that within six months you're totally
off
of
of the um uh statin drugs
because you're going to wind up getting
ms multiple sclerosis if you keep going
the way you're going
okay multiple sclerosis is due to a
cholesterol deficiency you get
demyelinization of the brain the brain
is 80 percent fat
and depending on the part of the brain
you're talking about it could be 25
percent 60 75 is cholesterol your body
makes cholesterol your brain cells make
cholesterol
cholesterol is not bad
right and so when doctors came out you
know 100 years ago and say oh
cholesterol causes plaque in the
arteries no plaque in the arteries
caused by salad dressings and cooking
oils and fried foods
causing inflammation
do you think that my
overall total cholesterol of 173 he
seemed to think that's still not within
range
well it's way too low
okay it's too low but he seems to think
it's not low enough
well that's because he has kids in
college and they need tuition
are you getting the picture here
yeah and even my triglycerides are down
to 86 from 161. i feel real good about
all this stuff but i'm kind of well
you're feeling feeling good about the
paper numbers but you're going to kill
yourself here
but i'm just saying i based on these
numbers i don't feel like i need to be
on all these medications well but don't
just cold turkey off of them you reduce
them by say 25 don't do them all at the
same time
okay i'd start with the statin drugs
reduce that by 25 and then two weeks
later test yourself again
okay
but
people's cholesterol should be 325.
and you're down below 200 yeah you're
in trouble
and so
uh guess what testosterone the male
hormone is 95 by weight cholesterol
you can understand drugs there ain't
nobody home anymore
and suddenly now you need to go to a sex
doctor because you
you've been taking all these statin
drugs and avoiding cholesterol and you
can't make you can't make testosterone
interesting
okay
so
that's why these doctors need to be sued
they need to go to jail
they need to have their licenses taken
away because they are running in the
wrong direction
because insurance pays just like ms
you know how much you know how much
insurance companies pay out in the
united states alone each year just to
treat symptoms of ms
i can't imagine
85 billion dollars the us government
came out with that just a couple of
weeks ago 85 billion dollars are spent
each year in america treating the
symptoms of ms multiple sclerosis
85 billion dollars are paid out by the
us insurance companies and you never
hear about that
i mean that should be front page news
every day
okay
and and
that's just paying for the symptom
treatment
85 billion dollars i mean that's more
than we spend on our military
so
so i with my ldl cholesterol that was
high that was 110 it should be about
less than 100 i shouldn't really worry
about that
yeah it should be up around 300 should
be around
300. the no the actual just the ldl
cholesterol yeah i'm talking about yeah
i'm talking about well your ldl
should be about um
oh two-thirds of your total cholesterol
okay
shellfish is good
well like shellfish is good of course
like everything else you can't have
fried oysters
no no i have fried shrimp
you know i just wanted an airfryer
no that's a frying it doesn't matter
where the temperature is coming from
whether it's
a grill see
they're killing people with these air
fryers
because you're heating those fats and
oils to frying temperatures it doesn't
matter it's over a flame or hot air i
gotcha okay
some of the most dangerous some of the
most dangerous politicians are dangerous
because of their hot air
okay
very good
yeah yeah
the
the thing about um
hot air
air fryers
is that they are less messy
okay they're more convenient for the
cook
but they're a killer
same outcome
okay
very good thank you so much for your
time and i'll check in and
uh yeah say two yeah two weeks yeah two
weeks four weeks six weeks it's
toll-free number doesn't cost you
anything to call
very good thanks so much yeah people
want to hear your story
thanks hp and if i may
i would like to add a little bit about
the air fryer people say well i don't
use oil in it well no you have food that
has oil already in it naturally
occurring and that heat is heating that
oil up and that's what we're talking
about not even an air fryer because
you're taking that natural oils in the
food
taking it to extreme heats
that's then
converting it
into
toxins for your body that are going to
kill you
so i just wanted to add a little bit of
clarity on that because i get that
question a lot
it's like well how about an air fryer no
not even an air fryer well i'm not using
oil
no you're not
but
technically you're not adding oil but
you are still using the oil that's in
naturally occurring in that food
that's right you hit the nail on the
head you're heating the natural fats and
oils in the meats
to frying temperatures
yeah which is usually over 400
degrees so and and higher depending on
the food
well dr welling let's go to
the next hand that is up and g lotte go
ahead and unmute yourself
if you have a camera go ahead and turn
that on
um hi doc i'm a big fan by the way okay
thank you where are you from
i'm from england
okay good day mate
thank you yeah big fan you're an amazing
human being i have them three quick
questions please okay
okay the first question is um
i am currently taking beyond tanki
tangerine 2.5
um can you explain the difference with
that and your ultimate classic liquid
please
well the the ultimate classic
um which i say
um
is a liquid multiple
okay
as opposed to the btt 2.5 is that's what
you're talking about okay
the btt 2.5
has much more
nutrients in it okay just look at the
number of nutrients just read the labels
and um uh
uh
you can take the btt 2.5
powder and tablets with you
places the liquid you can't it's just
you know too cumbersome
and so
um i would go with the btt 2.5 but i i
rather go with the healthy brain and
heart pack which is a complete program
it has the efas and all that other stuff
in that package
the ultimate
okay the btt
um
uh 2.0 uh the ultimate uh
excuse me the um
uh
yeah you just need all nine you need all
215 nutrients okay 215 nutrients okay
215 nutrients is in the healthy start
pack that's what i'm looking at the
healthy start pack to
okay that's the 90 and then
the
btt 2.0
is the next step up 215 nutrients as
opposed to 90. the 90's in there
but i like the bigger program healthy
brain and heart pack
215 nutrients is bigger than 90.
excellent okay
sorry i accidentally muted myself okay
thank you for that that was one question
um i do a lot of fasting um so i was
just wondering
um what the benefits are
um with taking youngevity products on an
empty stomach versus with a meal
okay well on an empty stomach you're
going to
absorb it more efficiently more rapidly
because it's not competing with surface
space with other food
so you're going to get a faster
uh hit from taking it on an empty
stomach
but fasting
you know goes back to the beginning of
time so it's not nothing new
and
if you're taking
your nutrients there's nothing wrong
with fasting
just stay away from air fryers
okay
well the last question is i've been on
um thyroid medication for three years
um so i'd just like to know the best
products
okay we have two products to add to the
healthy branded heart pack
for thyroid one of which is called
ocean's gold it comes from one ocean
it's uh
i think eight or nine different uh
seaweeds and stuff like that and
um
sea plants and
kelp and so forth and then we have
another one from the other ocean it's
called
uh fucoid z in capsules but we also have
a liquid form of the few choices in
capsules
same formula it's just a liquid it's
called z radical so you have your choice
but i take both
the
um
fucoid z capsules and i take also the
ocean's gold i take them both and i you
know i'm 83 years old i don't have any
thyroid problems
wow okay that's brilliant doctor wallach
yeah i'm a big fan god bless okay okay
do you live here in the states are you
calling from the uk
i'm i'm literally calling from the uk
yeah okay well thank you and give all
our friends in the uk a big hug for us
okay hello thank you okay god bless
thank you
all right dr wallach i have another
question coming in from the uk
and rad
is
has a question in regards to helping out
his dad his father who is 68
6 foot
240 pounds
three years ago
he had his hips replaced both of his
hips
he has a collapsing lumbar spine he's on
medication for blood pressure
he has
increased uric acid levels memory issues
can't recall folks names
white hair and mustache
he's on a beta blocker
medication for dehydration and
medication to lower the heart rate
what would you recommend for rad's
father dr wallach
okay
sounds like he's got osteoporosis to the
skull
and of course he got osteoporosis
everywhere
and um i'm sorry he's already had his
hips replaced i can't fix that
but i can tighten up the bones around
the the hip
replacement so they don't wobble around
in there and create pain
but at 242 pounds
rad's dad needs to get off all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no gluten no we probably around
those so sugar no carbonated drinks even
the diet one's got to go
because the carbonation neutralizes
stomach acid so you cannot efficiently
digest food or absorb minerals very
important
and then at 242 pounds
he's right on that cuts but i'd have to
take two healthy brain and heart packs
for months two healthy brain heart patch
per month i want him to take um
let's see here two bottles a month to
the
uh msm so you can take three with
breakfast through the lunch routine time
they're gonna support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue disc between
the vertebrae bone mexico itself
and then i want him to take the collagen
peptide to scoop with that with his
breakfast drink a scoop of that with his
dinner drink i also want him to have
because of the hybrid pressure i'm going
to get
two bottles a month maybe three but a
minimum of two vowels a month of our
ultimate daily classic tablets take
three breakfasts through dinner time
he may need in the beginning to take
three three times a day but take a
minimum of three twice a day of the
ultimate daily classic tablets don't
cold turkey off his medication for high
pressure but as the blood pressure
begins to go down he can slowly reduce
medication based on the numbers usually
it takes anywhere from two to six weeks
to get off the medication but he needs
to stay on that
ultimate data classic tablets forever
okay
and then
uh let's see here
for the memory we do have a product
called emory fx you take three of those
twice a day we also have a product
called synaptive which gives the brain
cells
the
nutrition they need to be able to create
chemicals chemicals to talk to their
neighboring
brain cells and get the memory back okay
and because he has a heart issue
i also uh let's see here i think we're
covering the heart to heart to heart to
heart
um yeah so i think we're covering almost
just about everything that needs to be
covered here he's six foot tall he's
he's on this program he's going to lose
a little bit of weight just because he's
staying away from the bad foods and at
six foot tall i like to see him weigh
200 205 kind of thing so he needs to
lose about 30 pounds and he'll lose
maybe half a pound every other day or so
on this program doesn't need to do our
special weight loss program here because
he's taking quite a bit of stuff
but give us a call every couple of weeks
and we will walk you guys through this
all right thank you so much dr wallach
it is break time everybody so get up and
stretch
make sure you get some movement going on
run to the restroom if you need to fill
up your cup throw in a splash of
minerals
in fact this one right here i have the
strawberry kiwi minerals mixed in with
it and also some of our renew iq which i
absolutely love that combination
um
just stay hydrated
make sure that your hydration is doing
your body good so everybody we will be
right back with ask doc life
okay and we are back with stock live
just as a reminder
if you were invited here by somebody
specific you want to make sure that you
get back with them if you have any
questions about what was discussed on
today's program and if you would like to
also start being more empowered of your
health journey
and get started on a protocol
that is dr wallach approved using the
supplements that we have found that
are a solution to replacing deficiencies
that are commonly associated with over
600 different diseases folks
600 that's a lot
so
askdoclive.com
that is where you will find all of the
replays for our astoc live program
we have them there since we started this
program almost two years ago so we
started in july of 2020
and in the hopes that more people will
see that we do have a broken medical
system
but we do not have to be dependent on a
system that is failing so many
we ourselves through the science of
epigenetics can have a
better control over where our health
journey takes us
so
share this program with others
make sure that they also know that they
can take control they do not have to be
dependent on pharmaceuticals
all right
so as soon as dr wally is back he's
going to get his headset back on
and we will be able to continue so i
hear you dr wally pretty soon you'll be
able to hear me
there we go
welcome back dr wallach
okay
are you ready to get started again we
have a lot of plans today
so let's go to the next guest who has
her hand up and
go ahead and unmute yourself thank you
for having your camera on you are online
with dr wallach
thank you for taking my call dr wallach
i really
hi i really feel like you're my last
hope for survival because i have oh my
gosh
i have such complicated health issues uh
you have a whole team here you have a
whole team here waiting
i'm so happy thank you uh i weigh 178
i'm 5'4 i'm 68 years old i've had four
heart attacks and a double bypass
type 2 diabetes
high blood pressure my kidney function
is at 30.
i'm having recent breathing attacks
and i have a charcoal foot with bone
transplants in both feet
thinning hair
no gallbladder
and a broken neck from an accident
so that's very complicated and i'm
just very unhappy with the medical
system and how i've been treated for
these conditions
yeah well your your doctor had kids in
college and needed tuition money so he
thanks you very much
yes okay
okay so you weigh
178 pounds okay yes
all right so this is not complicated it
sounds complicated but it's not
complicated
uh number one you need to get rid of all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens wheat
by ryan oats no sugar no carbon or
drinks even that one's got to go now
this is not only yourself this is
everybody in the household
this includes the dog and the cat and
you got to read the labels make sure
there's no gluten in there you got to
watch where you wash your clothes so
there's no cross-contamination in the
washer and dryer you got to watch
going to restaurants and i only eat
salads when i go to a restaurant but
then
the waitress who's bringing you your
salad just delivered three loaves of
bread and the table next to you and
she's covered in gluten dust
okay
and and so you got to pay attention to
those details right
yes then
uh at 178 pounds i want you to have two
healthy brain and heart packs for months
two healthy brain and heart pattern
month photos everything twice a day
that's the heart and brain brain and
heart okay
two healthy brain and heart packs per
month
photos everything twice a day
then i want you to get two bottles a
month
of our msm's you can take three at
breakfast three at lunchtime time
and they will support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between a vertebrae bone makes
your bone itself and all this knee stuff
and foot stuff and ankle stuff and toes
stuff and finger stuff and neck stuff
will go away do you have any ringing in
the ears
no do you have any vertigo or balance
problems
uh occasionally not much okay
okay uh do you have any uh
dental problems any things like um
dentures or
i have three dental implants okay okay
any receding gums anything like that
no
okay did you ever have bell's palsy or
trigeminal neuralgia pain in your face
no okay do you have anything you say you
got stuff going on your heart did you do
you have a diagnosis of um atrial
fibrillation anything like that
no
okay
uh you have high blood pressure right
yes
then i want you to take two vowels a
month of our ultimate daily classic
tablets ultimate daily classic tablets
take three of those twice a day
don't cold turkey off your medication
but as you know you need to continue you
know testing your blood pressure and as
your blood pressure comes down you can
slowly reduce the medication based on
the numbers might take you anywhere from
say two to six weeks to see some real
spectacular benefit but don't cold
turkey off the medication do it slowly
based on the numbers okay
same with the diabetes i get two bowels
a month of our sweetie so you take three
of those twice a day
and um again don't cold turkey off your
diabetes medication but as the blood
sugar comes down
you can slowly reduce the medication
based on the numbers now are you taking
metformin the oral stuff or are you
taking an injectable
metformin and insulin
both okay yeah because the metformin is
an oral thing the odds are you're not
going to get much benefit from the
metformin by itself
because you got you know damaged your
intestines from eating gluten and so
that's not going to be very valuable to
you for lowering blood sugar that's why
you're on both the doctor knows that
okay and
hmm
okay
then
i have lung issues
um that's why i want you to have that
healthy brain and heart pack because it
does have nutrients in there that's very
essential for the lungs the hair is a
good sort of barometer for what's going
on inside of you
do you color your hair
uh occasionally not often okay but the
hair color will come back and you'll
start growing more hair
okay your skin requires an enormous
amount of nutrition to grow hair
okay and so
um
when you have white hair it's not an age
thing it's a nutritional deficiency
effect the hair color comes back
and people say are you dyeing your hair
no i'm just taking you know my essential
factors here my hair is making its own
color again okay isn't that amazing
so i i think we've covered it here oh
you you have a gallbladder issues
okay i do want you to get our ultimate
daily now let me back up our ultimate
enzymes our ultimate enzymes take
ultimate enzymes i get a couple bottles
of those per month so you can take um
we call the gallbladder a bottle
okay
it's the ultimate enzyme gallbladder
bottle because it does have bile in it
we've taken the bile from the
gallbladders of beef that has been
killed in slaughterhouses we dry it
and um and put into these
enzymes okay they got the good lord put
the gallbladder in us for a purpose
yeah okay and that's to help you absorb
fat soluble vitamins a d e and k and
that kind of stuff also help you absorb
good fats to prevent lung diseases and
all kinds of skin problems and a lot of
hair loss and all this kind of stuff
so you need the good fats and the
gallbladder helps you absorb them every
time you eat a meal the gallbladder
contract squeezes bile into there to
help you absorb those
fats and fat soluble nutrients
um into your body okay from your
intestine so when the gallbladder is
gone you're not getting that
action
okay that's why you're having these
problems
so we've dealt with the heart we've
dealt with the diabetes we've dealt with
the high blood pressure
we've done with the lungs we dealt with
the hair and we dealt with the
gallbladder so i think we're good you're
gonna lose a few pounds
um just by getting rid of the bad foods
so at five foot four i'd like to see a
way maybe
um
140 so you'll lose 25 30 pounds it might
take you a month or two but you'll
you'll lose it just because you're
staying away from all the bad foods okay
give us a call every couple of weeks
because everybody's going to want to
hear what's going on to that and what
happens
what what hap what about the kidney
function that's my big concern okay well
the same thing that deals with high
blood pressure is going to help your
kidney function the kidney depends
on the arteries bringing in the
blood to get filtered
and so when it doesn't get enough blood
coming into the kidneys they they don't
like it
and so they rebel get all kinds of stuff
going on
but you're not on dialysis yet correct
no
okay well we can prevent that we we take
people that haven't urinated in 10 years
they're on dialysis six days a week and
in two weeks time
um they're urinating after 10 years and
so on this program and we get them down
to three days
um dallas instead of six and in two more
weeks they're totally off the dial says
they were on dialysis for 25 years
but the last 10 years they haven't
urinated so they're on dialysis
um six days a week okay and we we deal
with that all the time okay it's just a
matter of making the arteries happy in
the kidneys and then all the bad stuff
goes away
okay so i'm on the two packs of the 90
essentials daily do i continue that or
just go over to the brain in heart go
over to the brain heart because the
ultimate um
let's see the the healthy start pack
okay the healthy start pack is in
okay the 90 essential nutrients are in
the healthy branded heart pack the
healthy banana heart pack has 215
nutrients and 90 of which are in there
from the healthy shark pack okay
yes yes
okay you were thinking correctly you
just didn't have the whole package
okay so
there's hope
oh listen you're going to add 25 to 50
healthier life okay that's the goal here
uh i'm 83 years old
and most people think i'm in my 50s or
maybe even early 60s but certainly not
83 but i'm 83 and so it's one of those
things where i i can testify
that um
i know that i'm going to live well
beyond 120
okay and unless i get hit by a car or
something like that because you know i'm
not going to die of kidney failure i'm
not going to die of heart failure i'm
not going to die of you know any of that
kind of stuff okay
thank you thank you so much okay and
look forward to hearing from you again
soon god bless you dear
thank you thank you
bye-bye
there is definitely hope and
so keep going you are on a great start
let's just move right into the next hand
that is up doctor wildlife jennifer go
ahead and unmute yourself you're on live
with dr wallach my dear
thank you
i do have a question i'm um 190 pounds
i'm 5'4
i'm 58 years old i was diagnosed with
breast cancer last year
i refused chemo radiation and the
hormone blocker that they wanted me to
take
but i've always had reproductive issues
and um when i left the medical doctor i
went to my chiropractor and the first
thing she did was take me off of
gluten fried foods and other good at
least good good for your chiropractor
and i have been gluten-free for a year
and i was just wondering what you would
recommend for my situation
we want to stay gluten-free for the rest
of your life okay
yes
yeah are you coloring your hair
no i do not
so you have just a little bit of gray in
there not much
okay
um well gray hair is not due to age it's
due to nutritional deficiency so it
gives you a clue what's going on when
you have gray hair okay it's the clue
you're missing some nutrients okay
and so um and you weigh 190 pounds i i
apologize i didn't get how tall you were
i'm five four
five four
and since i have gotten off of gluten
and the other stuff i've lost 68 pounds
isn't that amazing
yes it's it's been amazing are you from
texas
no i'm not
south
south mississippi mississippi okay i'm
trying to figure out where the accent
was south mississippi okay
okay
all right so i want you to um
again at five foot four i'd like to see
weigh maybe
uh 130 pounds 120 pounds so we need to
lose a little bit of weight i want you
to
uh get our
keto shake one meal a day it's a meal
replacer it's not to add to a meal could
be any meal that you can have two meals
a day lunch to
two
you know just at lunch for monday and
tuesday wednesday and thursday could be
dinner thursday and friday could be
breakfast you know whatever
but it doesn't have to be the same meal
but it's a meal replacer it's not to add
to a meal one keto shake and you can
have two
of our rebound shakes or excuse our
rebound drinks with that and you'll be
able to there's a hundred nutrients in
our rebound shakes compared with red
bulls primarily sugar and and caffeine
in red bull right
so our sports drink is nutrition
and then um
uh at 190 pounds to start with i want
you to be on two healthy brain and heart
pasture month two healthy brain and
heart pattern that's our big big hammer
okay has 215 nutrients in it so
uh photos of everything at breakfast
food those are in dinner time
i also want you to take our fucoid z
i take three of those twice a day that's
two bottles a month that's gonna support
your immune system i also want you to
get our
um
let's see here
i need you to get
our um
okay
breast cancer oh um the
the um
i said i said the sports drink okay this
okay
the rebound there you go the rebound and
so let's just go there i do want you to
take the ultimate daily classic tablets
take three of those twice a day that's
two bottles a month that's gonna help
you with blood pressure and blood flow i
do want you to take also
our
um
uh two miles a month of our msm so you
take three breakfasts for illustrating
dinner time they're gonna support and
promote maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone
mixtures which is your bone marrow
okay which is your immune system here
which is really good for your
for your immune system
i also want you to take the collagen
peptides take a scoop of that breakfast
scoop that dinner time in your drink and
that's going to support again
your bone marrow
which is where your your immunity comes
from your white blood cells and
antibodies and so forth and your immune
system is your best friend here one last
thing on the immune system
okay we do have the killer biotic
as it's our reese mushrooms okay
and you want to take three of those
twice a day and you can actually go to
siri or online and say hey
give me some results of some research
done
with risi mushrooms and breast cancer
you'll get more information it'll blow
your mind how much information we know
on the use of rishi mushrooms to
help
you know in the therapy of breast cancer
because it supports the immune system
uh including the bone marrow okay
okay one last question what did you
recommend for the thinning hair okay
well again we have hair skin and nails
if you want to go to that hair skin and
nails you can take three of those twice
a day
um
and then
the hair growth will start coming back
we take people that are like bowling
balls for 40 years have don't have a
hair in their head for 40 years
and in four to six weeks on their
program the hair starts growing back and
in three months time
their their hair is full again and just
the same color it was when they were 12
years old
okay great yeah thank you so much i
appreciate it
okay
yeah and so it's one of those things
where we have a lot of experience we've
been doing this for 75 years
and so um
please do give us a call every couple of
weeks
you have questions you have results or
you have questions you don't have
results you know give us a call every
couple of weeks so it's toll free
doesn't cost you anything to call us
and people want to know whatever
happened to that jennifer girl you know
she had some interesting stuff going on
and we want to know how she's doing okay
so people want to hear from you
okay
dr wallach let's go to one of the
the
emails that i got today well it wasn't
today it was over the past week
but kieran is 67 years old
168 pounds
5 foot 3 inches some gray hair
has type 2 diabetes
hypertension
and she's on medication for the diabetes
medication for hypertension she just
found out
that she has 50 to 60 percent blockage
of one carotid artery
she does have varicose veins
and arthritis probably in all joints but
especially bothered by spinal arthritis
from the sacrum to the neck
including the loss of one inch
she experiences some dizziness and
tinnitus at times
says the bad cholesterol is too high
triglycerides are okay
um statin has been recommended but she
has refused she has acne eczema
restless leg syndrome difficult with
bladder control
and she's wanting to know what she needs
to take she's been sharing our program
with everyone she knows and figures she
should get herself straightened out and
become a distributor because she tells
everybody about
so where should we start with karen
okay well first of all she's got
osteoporosis in the skull that's why
she's got ringing in the ears she's got
dizziness and all that kind of stuff
she got osteoporosis to the skull and um
if she goes to some doctor they might
even say you know she has
multiple sclerosis
okay
so that's a possibility too
but all these things are just simple
nutritional deficiency issues
so none of the bad foods and she's been
working on that so it shouldn't be too
hard no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens no wheat by rhinos no
sugar no carbonated drinks either the
diet one's got to go
and at 168 pounds i wanted her to take
two healthy brain and heart packs per
month two healthy brain and heart
pressure month to full dose everything
twice a day 215 nutrients in that in
that pet okay 215 nutrients including
the 90 essentials
and then
i wanted to have two bottles a month
uh let's back up yeah two bottles a
month of the ultimate daily classic
tablets
okay ultimate daily classic tablets i
want her to take three of those twice a
day that'll support healthy blood
pressure
and
don't cold turkey off the medication but
as the blood pressure drops
she can slowly reduce the medication
based on the numbers uh diabetes i want
to get two bowels a month of our sweetie
so she can take three of those twice a
day again uh don't cold turkey off the
medication but as her blood sugar drops
she can slowly reduce medication and
stay on her
um sweeties
i also uh want her to have
the
um
let's see here
she needs vitamin d3 i wanted to take
three of those twice a day that's two
bottles a month
um and i think i said if i did msm she
needs the msm three of those
uh with breakfast for you with the
luxury of dinner time that'll be two
miles a month of the msm that's going to
support and promote mains repair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between the vertebrae bone
breaks upon itself
and
it's going to be an amazing thing for
her okay
and um
let's see here
uh she got clogged arteries so she does
need the ultimate daily classic tablets
ultimate daily classic tablets and she
needs to take three of those twice a day
that'll support healthy blood flow
through blocked arteries in her brain
her heart coronary arteries and her
kidneys
and every place else and also support
healthy blood flow and also support
healthy blood pressure
so she's got a an intense program here
so she needs to be in touch with us like
um
every two weeks and we'll walk her
through this because she's going to have
a great testimony as the call is
toll-free and so people are going to
want to know
uh what's going on with that karen girl
with all those problems she's got
okay and this is not unusual
because when people
have a gluten problem they cannot absorb
nutrition and so it's not unusual for
people to have 8 10 12 15 20 different
diseases or on 20 different medications
you're seeing 18 different doctors
but insurance pays so who cares right
but see this is all wrong because it's
telling you she's not getting the
nutrition she needs because she's eating
gluten weep around oats
and again some doctors might say she has
ms multiple sclerosis
um because she got these things going on
in her head in her head but it's
osteoporosis of the skull that's why i
say osteoporosis skull ms
um and
um
uh guillain-barre
disease
the three of them i believe are the same
disease just varying
it depends on
which which um
part of the body is more severely
impacted so you get a slightly different
percentage of symptom range but just the
same basic
um pathology
okay
back to you
and dr wellick one thing that i wanted
to add to that as if you're eating by
the usda pyramid
they say that grains are supposed to be
the biggest part of your diet and those
are killing you they were me
yeah well you're exactly right you're
exactly right um
thank you that's one of the reasons i
love you
you're you're very thoughtful for
everybody else um the
the
loss of nutrients
is a terrible terrible thing
and we see this so often
and
doctors just want to give prescriptions
for the symptoms
just for
ms multiple sclerosis alone 85 billion
dollars a year in the united states
alone just to treat the symptoms that's
what the insurance companies are paying
out did you ever hear that before
85 billion dollars
and think about it dr wallach what about
those of us who who were not billing
through
insurance and paying out of pocket
that doesn't include us
that's correct
so the number even greater
it's insane
and here i'm spending even
not even a fraction of that not even
like a
millionth of that
and i'm achieving optimal health i'm a
loving life i look forward to getting
older
you and i have birthdays coming up real
soon
and
yeah and and it's it's absolutely
fabulous not to be
ailing
so
and yes there is lots of hope lots of
hope
okay let's go to our
go ahead dr what were you gonna say no
nothing just go ahead
okay well let's go to our next hand that
is up and karina go ahead and unmute
yourself
hello can you hear me
yes ma'am
okay um so we already talked one of my
questions was going to be about thyroid
stop
tell me who you are how old you are
which away
um
so my name is karina i am
5'5 and i weigh 170 now 165 now and um
i am on the healthy brain and heart pack
and uh various other things i'm on both
of the things you mentioned for thyroid
i have hypothyroidism
um on the np thyroid right now which i'm
trying to
um get off of and he'll heal the thyroid
so i have to be on that anymore and so i
am on both of the things you mentioned
when the other person asked i'm on the
bucy and also the ocean's gold so um
things are getting um better i've lost
some weight i've been on the program
been gluten free and done your eating
program have your cookbook all of that
so my question for you is when we go to
um the doctor this last time
my sister has hypothyroid too and so
they're saying
that they wanted to increase her
medication and
i'm wondering if any of the things that
we're taking
would affect the lab test because so
many of them say stop taking everything
for three days before
you come for your test and i didn't know
if that would include any of the
supplements that were on if that would
affect the lab results if we should stop
taking everything which you know i don't
want to stop taking my nutrients for
three days this seems dumb but i just
wanted to ask you if there was any truth
to the fact of what we should stop
taking before we go for labs okay well
see they can't believe that you're under
control
okay because they don't understand the
nutrition piece of it so they want to
see if you stop taking your supplement
your drugs if your
numbers go bad again okay now you didn't
give me um
how much you weigh
you said 170 pounds
165 yeah 165 okay how old are you
i'm 50.
50. okay all right so you have thyroid
issues what else you got you're coloring
your hair
yes
okay
and so again uh hair loss to hair color
is not due to age it's due to a
nutritional deficiency so that's why i'm
asking
and uh do you have any other issues how
about pressure diabetes
no
okay um do you have anything like uh
celiac or
or irritable bowel syndrome
diverticulitis anything like that
no thankfully
any high blood pressure
no
okay all right so this is fairly simple
at 170 pounds i want you to get rid of
all the bad foods and this is for our
listeners also uh no bad foods and
you're already working on that no fried
foods no processed meats no oils no
glutens no wheat no butter i know so
sugar no carbohydrate drinks even the
air fryers are out no frying foods no
air fryers okay
and then
you need um 170 pounds i want you to
take two healthy brain and heart packs
per month two healthy brain and heart
patch per month to full dose everything
twice a day i'm going to take two
bottles a month of our msm so you can
take three at breakfast street lunch
through dinner time they will support
and promote maintenance repair cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue disc
between vertebrae bone ranks the bone
itself
and of course
it also includes dealing with the skin
which is two-thirds of your skin
thickness it's connective tissue kind of
like tendons and ligaments kind of thing
and i do want you to take our ocean's
gold for thyroid take three of those
twice a day there's two bottles a month
you can also take our pukoid z if you
want i take both if you call it z take
three of those twice a day that's two
bottles uh per month and they're from
two different oceans but in each case
it's a combination of dried seaweed
algae
plankton all kinds of different things
okay in there you're getting all these
wonderful minerals and things
which makes the thyroid happy and it'll
help you lose weight because when people
gain weight just because they're
minimally deficient they develop a
behavior called pica and when you have
pika even if you eat a 3 000 calorie
meal you're still hungry you just keep
eating and eating and eating and eating
because your body's looking for that
missing nutrient so you take the
nutrients and suddenly now
why are you leaving your food you
usually gobble that up in ten minutes
why why did you leave half your plate
are you okay
well yeah i just not hungry okay well
that's because you're taking the
essential factors and now you don't have
pica anymore okay
so all that will work for you and then
i've definitely seen that
okay good and so the hair
thing i take people who've been bald
like a bowling ball for 40 years don't
have one single hair in their head for
40 years
and say
two to four weeks they start growing
hair and in two three months their hair
is all back again
the color it was when they were 12 years
old and they're freaking everybody out
because everybody's saying did you have
implants so how do you have so much hair
now
yeah
okay give us a call every couple of
weeks it's toll-free
okay and so there's no reason though to
go off the nutrients it won't skew the
like the thyroid levels that they're
testing
yeah that's why they want you to get off
your medication for the thyroid because
they can't believe you're doing so good
okay
so so see they think there's something
wrong with their lab tests
yeah right that's got to be it it's got
to be it
because you can't get well you can't get
well without their stuff
right right of course not
okay thank you so much karina thank you
all right thank you karina great
information shared there
let's go to the next hand that is up and
mark go ahead and unmute yourself
okay mark you're on the air
good morning
hello
good a couple of things um
where are you from where we're going
rancho cucamonga california
okay it's afternoon
yes it's the morning it's uh 9 30 in the
morning
okay
what's up
i'm just to let you know i'm 6'1 i'm 60
years old i'm 6 1 200 pounds
a couple of things i'm generally in
pretty good health i believe i'm not a
doctor so that's just how i feel
a couple of things recently i've noticed
my blood pressure seems to be creeping
up
i generally most of my life
k always came in um 100 over 60 110 over
61 10 over 70.
now i'm generally about 140 over
80 or 90 a lot of the times that i check
it
or 135 maybe over 70 75
so that's number one
the second thing is
it may have something to do with it just
to go back seven years i had a road
bicycling accident
and was in a coma for two months
and glory to god i'm here talking so
other than that
i do have some nerve damage in my right
lower leg i'm kind of interested is
anything
that you know that we could do about
that
other than that i'm i'm feel pretty good
i feel fortunate so
okay
let's see i can't have a hat on so i
can't tell you how many white grays over
here
burn me do you have any white gray or
silver hair
oh yeah it's it's all great okay would
you look at that okay that has nothing
to do with age that says you're you're
severely minerally deficient
okay hair color loss of hair color means
you're severely minerally deficient that
is not an aging thing
i'll get your hair i'll get your normal
hair color back what's your normal hair
color brown black it was a dark brown
okay well be prepared because in six
months time your hair will be dark brown
again that'd be great
yep so it tells you you're absorbing so
none of the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat by rhinos no sugar no carbonated
drinks even the dot one's got to go
and then i want you to have two healthy
brain and heart packs for months two
healthy brain and heart pattern months
full dose everything twice a day
full dose everything twice a day okay
then um
then i want you to take two bottles a
month of our
msm take three at breakfast street lunch
or dinner time that's gonna help you
with your joints and uh your skin and
walls of your arteries and all that kind
of stuff anything made out of connective
tissue tendons and ligaments and back
and discs between the vertebrae and all
that stuff will regrow okay
so don't forget that
um
then because you have this blood
pressure issue i want you to take two
bottles a month of our
ultimate daily classic towel let's take
three at breakfast dinner time
and um
see how much that helps you
i'm sorry when you repeat that one
please
ultimate daily classic tablets okay
ultimate day
yeah two bottles a month so you take
three twice a day and it will support
and promote healthy blood pressure
okay and so give us a call every couple
of weeks let us know what your blood
pressure is and
um
i'd go ahead and take a picture with
your cell phone or something or have
somebody take a picture of your hair
and like every every four to six weeks
take a picture of your hair and see what
it looks like every four to six weeks
and the roots will come in darker brown
okay
and then
um
do you have any blood sugar problems any
diabetes anything like that pre-diabetes
no
no nothing
okay good like i said pretty much as
everything's normal as far as that goes
okay
go ahead go ahead
i have something that this goes back i
believe my it's part of my family my mom
on my mom's side was from the
mediterranean and something called
thalassemia when i was a children child
so
it may be a form of anemia that you
don't have
yeah yeah thalassemia
okay has to do with your bone marrow
okay
it's almost like sickle cell anemia kind
of thing
okay but it's it's just not making happy
healthy
red blood cells
but that's thalassemia is very easily
dealt with it's not genetic in any way
shape or form it's not autoimmune in any
way shape or form
okay it's location location location
okay where you are what you're eating
what you're not eating
okay
so let's go
ahead and
i'm sorry just two more things i do i
have used the uh btt 2.5 now for about a
year
i
i found out about
critical health news from falling asleep
to george nori at night
so and the other thing
guys i really like that i'd like
just the one thing not all the you know
40 pills that you take every day
and then i would like to use a lose 15
pounds what do you suggest it seems like
the older i get and i eat well
i don't no processed foods no carbonated
drinks except for a beer now then
but okay well it's okay stop
beer has gluten in it it's made from
wheat okay unless you're drinking rice
beer
is made from wheat gluten gluten alert
gluten alert gluten alert
okay
and then if you're gonna drink beer
drink rice beer from asia or australia
new zealand
okay
um
but uh also
you need to be very careful
uh when it comes to
um what you're gonna do what you're not
gonna do okay
and so you just can't take one product
even our btt 2.05 or 2.5 is one of the
greatest multiples on earth but it's not
complete
okay you still need other things you
still need water you still need oxygen
you still need
maybe depending on what's going on your
joints you still need more
um sulfur and stuff like that that's why
you're taking the msm
okay for the extra sulfur
um
let's see here
um and again the high blood pressure the
ultimate daily classic tablets
uh take three of those twice a day as we
said your blood pressure will start
coming down
uh don't cold turkey off your medication
if you're on medication but as the blood
pressure drops you can slowly reduce the
medication based on the numbers
might take you two to six weeks to get
off your medication for high blood
pressure i'm not i'm not on any
medication okay okay good excellent okay
well give us a call every couple of
weeks and uh you know keep track of what
you're taking what you're not taking
uh your numbers and we'll walk you
through this and people want to find out
what's happening with mark
no
toll free you bet yes sir
have a good day
thank you mark
all right dr wallach let's go to the
next hand that is up and rebecca go
ahead and unmute yourself
hello rebecca
you're on with dr wallach
hi dr wallach hi hi rebecca
hi rebecca how can we help you
well we spoke about three weeks ago
and you gave me some counsel about
my
thyroid and my type 2 diabetes
and i've lost about 7 pounds which isn't
huge but it's a start
right direction
and uh i've been working on cutting out
the bad foods
and eating the good foods
and i uh
i'm wondering i take the sweeties
along with the other things that you um
suggested
but
how old are you how do you rebecca
i'll be 52 next month okay and how much
you weigh
uh
uh now about
uh uh
let's see i was 285 i'm like
270.
okay we're going the correct direction
okay yeah and then what was the end of
my oh my five five eight
okay
yeah and so um we're going the right
direction so just again for the rest of
our people
um with these issues
you need to be getting rid of all the
bad foods no fried foods this will be
forever no fried foods no processed
meats no oils no glutens and when i say
no fried foods this means no air fryers
no deep fryers no frying at all right
no fried foods no processed meats no
oils or glutens and wheat nobody rhinos
no sugar no carbon or drinks even the
diet one's got to go because
because the carbonation in the diet
drinks neutralizes stomach acid so you
cannot absorb minerals or digest food
you still so you can't even have the
diet drinks that's why we have the
rebound sports drink has a hundred
nutrients in it okay red bull has
sugar and caffeine we have a hundred
nutrients
in our rebound
yeah but i found the ingredients it has
tea in it green tea
and i don't drink tea i don't drink tea
and coffee
oh
so i wondered if there was another
suggestion you had
um just
for the nutrients i mean like yeah drink
drink water
drink water okay
okay so then
um for the thyroid issues again we have
the
uh oceans gold
okay
ocean gold take take three of those
twice a day the fucoid z take three of
those twice a day
and uh
and then the diabetes uh two of our
um
the two of the sweeties so you can take
three twice a day um don't cold turkey
off your medication in either case the
thyroid are your diabetes but as the
numbers get better you can slowly reduce
medication based on the numbers okay
and um are you taking did you get one of
the keto shakes one meal a day keto
shake i did i got the strawberry and i'm
replacing now do do i need to place the
same replace the same meal every day or
no no just as long as it's one of the
meals one meal a day but it's a
replacement you hit it right on the head
it's a meal replacer it's not right to
add to a meal don't ask a meal it's a
meal replacer but it does not have to be
the same meal every day based on your
schedule okay
now my i'm having a hard time with my
blood sugar numbers they're staying kind
of high
are you taking the sweeties i am
as well as my insulin and my metformin
and i'm still having a hard time i
originally was at a1c of 13.8
and i was able to get the numbers down
to 8.9 okay go in the right direction
right
but i i don't know if it's the stress of
trying too hard which can affect
no
no uh do you live in a household with
other people
i do
do they gluten
probably there's your problem you're
getting cross-contaminated in the food
preparation surfaces you're getting
you're getting kind of
cross-contaminating the laundry the
couches the beds the rugs
you're swimming and gluten
right
you're not absorbing efficiently you're
not absorbing
the medication or the supplements
efficiently that's your problem
oh okay i thought maybe craig i was
craving sugar and missing a mineral
well yeah but that's because you're
taking all these supplements you're
still craving that means you're not
absorbing that means that you're getting
cross-contaminated your intestines are
damaged
all right you got to get everybody safe
get them out of the house or you get out
of the house or something
um you gotta really watch the cross
contamination
you can't wash your you need to run the
laundry empty
with all the detergent and everything in
it without your clothes in it before you
put your clothes in for a wash okay
yeah
you have to
you have to make sure you're not washing
your clothes
immediately following them washing their
clothes you can't wash your clothes at
the same time they're washing their
clothes because you get
cross-contaminated
okay
all right
okay give us a call in two weeks and
four weeks and six weeks you're gonna
have a great story
okay i i wanted to ask rebecca a
question real quick if i may
go for it
rebecca you said when i called the first
time to be in touch with you and i
didn't know how to do that on ask doc
live
so if you go to our website
askdoclive.com use the contact us option
and send an email
okay
all right thank you
you're very welcome
all right dr welling thank you rebecca
you're doing great i love progress over
perfection folks
don't put that stress of having to meet
perfection it's all about being grateful
for the progress progress one step at a
time
one step at a time that's right
with the biggest hammer in the box folks
[Laughter]
let's go to larissa doctor wallach
larissa go ahead and unmute yourself if
you're is that what no is that with an m
or an l are you saying low risk
yeah
okay
go ahead and say something larissa i
think we can hear ya can you hear me
yes ma'am you're on live with dr wallach
hi dr wallach such a pleasure
how can we help you
um i am five seven
weigh 215
which is down 72 pounds from where i had
been previously oh congratulations
thank you i'm 53 years old
i take the healthy body brain and heart
pack and have for um quite a few months
now
i'm on iodine and recently added the
ocean's gold
um have hypothyroidism and have been on
we have a lot of thyroid talk today have
been on levothyroxine for like 30 years
oh my gosh
terrible i i want off i'm just recently
i went to the doctor and my labs had
gone the wrong direction which surprised
me i had high tsh and then low t4 so my
doctor wants to increase my thyroid
medication
um i don't want to do that obviously at
least want to change to the natural
hormone if i have to take it
okay you don't have to take it so what i
want you to do
is take um go ahead and
how many of the oceans gold are you
taking today
i just recently started that one so just
um whatever it says i need but i doubled
it for my weight but whatever yeah you
need to take three or four twice a day
okay
and again stay away from all the bad
stuff
yeah okay i've been doing gluten free
for um almost well eight or nine months
now as well all the all the bad food
okay good
and then at 215 pounds once you have two
of the healthy brain and heart packs per
month two healthy brain and heart packs
from out to photos everything twice a
day all right
do you have anything going on with your
blood pressure or diabetes
no
okay good anything going on with your
joints your back
um yes i have been diagnosed both knees
uh bone on bone so i do take the osteo
that's in the brain and heart pack the
liquid i added flex care and i'm going
to start adding the msm
instead because it has more than the
flex care yes you need yeah you
definitely need the msm i'd go ahead and
take three with each meal it'll be two
bottles a month don't forget the
um collagen peptides take a scoop of
that in your morning drink take a scoop
down your eating drink that'll help you
build your bone marrow very important
here
um
let's see here
vitamin d three three of those twice a
day
doing that
okay good
and uh so yeah the the
bones respond very quickly
they're hungry for nutrients and they
will respond very quickly
i had read that that that biotin and i
do take lots of collagen can sometimes
um mask the lab results so could it be
that my lab result is inaccurate i don't
feel like i know what it feels like when
your thyroid is off
and so it surprises me that she said it
was so high could
anything i'm doing be masking and those
lab results be inaccurate did she give
you copies of the lab work
um she told me the tsh is
oh no oh no
not this time and should they only do
the tsh and t4 which bothers me because
that's not a full picture all right well
you sell everyone copies of all your lab
work from the beginning through now okay
okay
this was just a maintenance thyroid
check for the medication so it was only
thyroid
yeah we do here we do need to know
exactly what the lab test said because
when they just tell you what the lab
test said they can they can say anything
they want that's true
okay and so
um
doctors are some of the most dishonest
people on earth
agreed
okay they have kids in college they need
tuition money so they'll say whatever
they need to say to get to do another
test to take another medication whatever
okay yeah i just didn't know if that
test could be wrong based on something
i'm taking
well we have to see the tests for me to
answer the questions
okay i'll get that
we need to see the tests from
um you know when they started taking
them the test from six months ago and
the test from this last one let's see
what it looks like
okay because i have so many people you
know they're really doing good and the
doctor says okay you got to stop
whatever you're doing because your lab
test doesn't look right
yeah that means and i feel better than i
have in
years well they can't believe that
you're getting better because they've
never seen anybody get better right
right and and so you know it's one of
those things where
um
they got to
get you
they say look just take the
four food groups and the seven food
group pyramid you'll be fine don't take
any vitamins and minerals
now whenever you have doctors saying
that kind of stuff say uh sorry um i'm
gonna cancel all my appointments i'm
going somewhere else
i wanna go see a vet i'm gonna go see a
veterinarian
yeah
exactly
okay i just felt those lab results hard
to believe so i wanted to make sure i
was doing well but you would but you
didn't see the lab results you just took
her she just told you that it didn't
look good
okay
all right okay
mike didn't look good for her because
she's losing money
exactly
thank you dr wallick okay let's let's
hear the results
all right take care and god bless
you too
all right thank you larissa
let's go ahead and move on but first i
want to remind everybody
that if you were invited to watch this
program by somebody specific get back
with them and say hey thank you for
sharing that information with me i have
hope
that my health does not have to keep
declining
so there's a lot of hope that's being
shared here today we've had some
testimonials of people feeling better
larissa is one of them
and i just think it's fabulous dr
wallach to have people come in and share
share their testimony
absolutely it is
can't thank you enough for you and your
team all the things you do
for these people god bless you
well if it wasn't for you though dr well
like we wouldn't have somebody that has
the credibility that you have with the
experience
to be able to share with these good
folks so i am honored that we're able to
go around the world with this
information we are a team
a team yes we are and we have plenty of
room on our team if you've ever thought
of wanting to
have something to do in your spare time
your full time
doesn't matter
we i started out working this around
just everyday life
i focused on myself first i was getting
great results and people were asking me
what are you doing different
and that's where my business started
um and
i wouldn't change it for the world it's
been fabulous dr wally
before we're beginning up on time
to only the beginning that's right only
the beginning
let's go to mike who has his hand up
mike go ahead and unmute yourself my
friend
you're on
dr wallach great
how you doing doc
fine sir thank you how can we help you
okay well uh not for me but for my mom
uh i'm all good i'm off all my
medications i've been doing the protocol
for over a year and i feel great but i
did want to give one testimony when i
i hear people talking about cholesterol
and my cholesterol was always about 220
and when i got off my medication
my cholesterol you know i slowly came
off of it my cholesterol went to like
but uh
yeah i feel great though i'm not feeling
sluggish or anything wrong with me it
just it went up
just remember your brain is a
significant part of your brain weight is
cholesterol
95 of the weight of testosterone is
that's why you feel great because you
don't have these drugs suppressing your
testosterone and suppressing your brain
right so anyway here's why i called my
mom fell a couple weeks ago and broke
her shoulder she's five foot
160 pounds 84 years old
and here's my question
after that it happened she couldn't lay
down because of course it presses her
back and moves her shoulder and drives
her the pain was
outrageous but what's happening is
her her legs and her ankles and her feet
are swelling up a lot so finally i've
gotten her to where she can lay down and
put her feet up over her heart at night
when she goes to sleep and she wakes up
in the morning and everything's good but
after a couple of hours it starts
creeping back and her feet start
swelling up again and i was just
wondering uh what what can i do for that
okay is she why is it happening
it's eating protein or she just eating
bread
no no no i got her eating protein i i
got her on the 90 you know she's on the
protocol i i just you know i got her
doing everything that i can get i don't
forget
okay if she has
accumulation of edema stuff like that
she may not have enough protein okay she
can also she could also have a problem
with vascular stuff so don't forget the
ultimate daily classic tablets 160
pounds you can take three of those twice
a day that'll support healthy blood
pressure healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries and all that kind of
stuff
also helper veins
and and again blood flow
um
but she does need to eat protein with
every meal it could be chicken it could
be fish it could be beef
um
she just can't eat beans all the time
right okay yeah i get it
oh don't forget eggs she needs to eat a
couple of eggs with soft yolks twice a
day okay that'll help that'll help
okay
okay and let's see how all that works
okay we'll try that out doc
okay thank you thank you uh all your
help
well you best
we appreciate you sharing your mom's
story
yeah hi becca
all right thanks mike
all right dr wellick we're at the top of
the hour
i can't believe it is already
time
to say
farewell
and
on behalf of myself and my co-hosts
which i'm trying to get them all up here
because they are so fabulous
um ruthel and sanchez and dr judy and
jonty mccollier
are you ignoring me jaunty there you are
awesome we just want to say
thank you everybody for joining us on
ask doc live
spreading this information
that is helping so many folks around the
world that are being failed by a broken
system
our hearts
are in it 100
because we've experienced it ourselves
and we do
want to make sure that
others are able to experience this and
have hope that they do not have to be
chemical dependent
we're deficient folks
and it's not a chemical we're deficient
of
and dr wellick has proven that through
all of his research through
putting his research into action into
formulas
that
are just making a huge impact in a very
positive way and dr wallach thank you
for allowing us to be part of this
well we love you guys and it's one of
those things where we're a team
and it takes an army and that's was my
goal i figured this out many years ago
was to build an army because i knew that
you know i mean even god has an army
okay
even god requires
saints and other people to help him do
his will so god needs an army i said oh
my gosh i really need to get busy here
to get people trained so they can help
because this is not anything that one
person can do
no it's not and the one thing that i
want to make sure everybody knows you do
not have to be a doctor to help somebody
it's a beautiful thing
oh it is we have coaches from all walks
of life in all different countries at
all different
um
stages in life young middle-aged old
and so many different occupations
it doesn't matter there there's no
prejudging there's no minimum
requirements
other than having a heart for others and
having an open mind
to
look for
options
that aren't being shown in commercials
folks
so everybody
thank you for joining us on
askdoclive.com
if you
did not hear about this program by
somebody specific or through one of our
newsletters
we do have a call team for those that
have never spoken to anybody about any
of the products that dr wallach has
mentioned today
that call team is standing by at eight
five five
nine
four nine
seven two three four or again you can go
to the askdoclive.com
website where you will find dr wallach's
most popular books you will find a
store with all of the products that dr
wallach mentioned today
and the contact us
if you want to speak with somebody
specific to find out what you yourself
need
use that contact us and one of our
health coaches maybe even myself will be
getting back to you with information to
help you choose a better health journey
my name is rebecca dukes kozak
and we thank you for joining us on ask
doc live bye for now bye-bye and thank
you
thank you dr wallach see you next week
absolutely week everybody
have a great holiday everyone
yes be safe
and go for that go for the rice beer
if you have to go alcohol
keep it gluten-free
bye for now folks bye-bye